I guess I'm just taking a break we had
this really cool adventure saving earth
and that was pretty happy anyway so I
needed some me time and I came to
Australia and that's when I moved in
with Daryl hello
and here we are oh it's a nice flat as
you can see and we get along well yeah I
guess I just wanted to be around average
everyday people Daryl with an average
sort of everyday guy so it works out
well while I'm here I'm trying to get
involved with the lobby's who's this
purple weirdo surprise who actually knew
that was him to give back to the
community Daryl here is a buena crafter
electronic letter and writing to Captain
America and Iron Man there seems to be
something very intense going on between
them and I want to offer my help with my
services dear Tony Stark how's it going
I heard you and Captain America we're
having some relationship problems dear
Steve Rogers do you remember when i
goaded you into killing those prisoners
and you made me swear to never tell the
other Avengers if there's any other
secrets you need kept just let me know
as I'm not up to much you know what are
you doing later I was working what's he
doing he's working keep out Daryl go
through four battles the Mjolnir over
here taking a nap a little bit of
something I've been roasting in the Sun
for a number of weeks now it's almost
ready
delicious question what are Infinity
stones a lot of information and ideas
what I like to call little clues
speckled around the place and who is the
man in the purple chair is purple is a
magic love doesn't like standing up fury
what does he really know and is fury his
real name as it actually pronounced
furry little Milne here there are
sunglasses in case gets bright in the
Rainbow Bridge which often it does if
you lift up this little thing and what's
he holding me I never wear cut-offs how
do I keep waking up
come hops normal pants going in cut-offs
coming out you hmm
if I might wait heard from Tony Stark
and Captain America didn't contact you I
haven't received a single phone call one
shape son
oh hey t-bone how many times do we have
to go over this no amount of money is
gonna get me to join your little pissing
contest what here talk to Thor yeah he's
sort of been waiting here from you
I haven't right here I can't right now
okay am I disappointed they didn't
invite me to fight with him um no he has
two Heineken touch with you I don't I
don't have a phone he doesn't have a
phone send a raven I just start my own
team team for of course and it would be
me and Darren just us Bridey yep
more more and more less probably more